说他很失望，
你问他要钱，
我靠，
你比我大20岁，
我跟你在一起，
我不图你挣钱能力强，
我不图你条件好，
我图你什么？
他说那话是不是不要脸，
而且你跟他刚开始在一起的时候，
你还没花上他的钱，
还花你的钱，
而且你还给他白打工，
她还不给你发工资。
我是99年的，
我男朋友是七七年的，
我们认识四年了，
最开始的时候是她让我去她的公司上班，
但是当时呢，
实际上就她一个人，
除了我呢，
没有别的员工，
因为我在他之前只谈过一个男朋友，
所以就迷迷糊糊在一起了，
他没有给我发过工资，
比如说候吃饭啊，
买那个东西啊，
都是我花钱，
最多的时候呢，
刷了2万多的信用卡给他送礼，
后来呢，
我觉得他是骗子，
我就走了，
当时我自己在做直播，
一天可以卖四五千块钱的货，
第二年他就来找我了，
他说他觉得亏欠于我，
要给我投资，
我以为是开玩笑的，
结果真投资了，
投了100个，
但是没赚，
亏了。
第三年他让我来他的城市，
我来了，
但是他当时不让我上班，
觉得在这儿没有什么价值，
就待了两三个月，
我就走了，
期间呢一直在旅游，
他会给钱，
我会不停的往返两个城市，
今年呢，
他们场地扩大，
让我在做一个项目，
但是呢，
他没有任何的资源支持，
我一直在挨骂，
他们不停的骂我，
说我听不懂他们那种人的话，
但是他自己本身也没有很好的办法做这个事儿，
他说每个月给我3万块钱的工资。
话我是很正常的，
我跟他说我不做了，
我要走，
她就说她感觉我要离开他了，
那天晚上就怀孕了，
怀孕了之后呢，
她从来没有正确的解决这个问题，
在刚开始知道怀孕的第一时间，
她反而骂了我一顿，
因为我要跟他聊孩子的规划，
她说我聊规划的都是韭菜，
最后呢，
拉扯了半个月以后吧，
我说我有15万，
让他给我35万，
我们存钱给孩子50万，
我们就要这个宝宝，
她当时同意了，
但是呢，
他又没有做到，
我们约定7天，
他给我35万，
到了第5天的时候，
他说他只有22万，
他也不愿意借钱，
说他这两年把所有的钱都给我了，
但是我依然在问他要钱，
他觉得很失望，
觉得我是图他的钱，
最后呢，
他给了我22万，
让我要孩子，
这中间没有任何关系，
很敷衍，
我跟他闹，
他就说了分手就消失了，
我认识他以前是没有HPV的，
现在52是阳性，
我威胁他，
他跑了，
但在他已经走了，
不过我知道他公司在，
他不可能不回来，
我还要不要找他，
我想让他道歉，
我的问题是，
第一个他是不是一开始就不想要这个孩子，
第二，
他一直说他给钱就不需要关心，
我跟他吵了，
我的HPV在后期如果有问题，
我能不能让他负责，
第三，
我们公司呢，
说是以他们公司在做，
但是实际上所有的做网店嘛，
都是我的名下，
我们没有任何协议，
公司现在还有。
几万块钱我能不能提现？
第四，
我现在的存款大概是150个，
后续我的规划是该怎么样规划？
姑娘啊，
第一，
他不光是不想要这个孩子，
他从一开始也没想过要你，
为什么你想啊，
他说那话真的挺臭不要脸的，
他比你大20多岁，
对不对？
他说他很失望，
你问他要钱，
我靠，
你比我大20岁，
我跟你在一起，
我不图你挣钱能力强，
我不图你条件好，
我图你什么？
他说那话是不是不要脸，
而且你跟他刚开始在一起的时候，
你还没花上他的钱，
还花你的钱，
而且你还给他白打工，
他还不给你发工资，
没有发过工资。
对呀，
他就是个臭不要脸的老登，
我觉得啊，
作为一个有钱的老登，
最起码的道德应该明确的知道，
年轻的姑娘看上你，
肯定是看上你的赚钱能力了，
你如果跟年轻的姑娘在一起的话，
你最起码在物质上对年轻的姑娘也要有所照顾，
这才是一个有钱的老登该有的自我修养。
像你遇到这种老登的话，
就是臭不要脸，
一点老登的自我修养都没有。
而且我不认为他很成功，
他是又没有钱，
又穷又装老登，
又还骗年轻的姑娘，
又还不负责任，
他不光是不想要这个孩子，
他也不想要你。
第二个问题是他一直说他给我了22万，
他就不需要关心我在医院的情况，
我当时就跟他吵了，
HPV如果有，
真的是有实质性问题，
还能让他负责吗？
这个很难，
因为HPV和跟他之间的亲密关系之间未必是因果。
关系未必是一对一的因果关系，
因为HPV的发生它有很多种可能性，
所以说后续的治疗未必能够要求他来付这个钱，
这个是我给你的答案啊。
第3个你的网店在你名下，
你当然可以提现了，
你们之间又没有白纸黑户的协议，
当然可以提现了，
是你名下的就是你的啊，
那这个公司里现在还有一些货，
我可以卖这些货吗？
当然只要在你名下的，
这个公司的营业执照是我们的营业执照，
不过呢，
他的投资什么的全部都没有合同，
对，
没有任何合同，
只是这个货买了库房，
这个仓库我们没有付租金，
没有合同的情况下，
你承担了一种风险，
就是说看他这个钱是怎么入公司的账的，
如果这个钱是直接他个人打造公司的，
将来有可能他和公司之间有一个合同纠纷，
因为你没有白纸黑字，
如果说他的这个钱并没有过你的手，
只是买了货，
买了这个合同，
买了各种各样的产品的话，
那就风险不大，
因为他要打官司的话，
他也是跟合同的相对方去打官司，
跟你就没关系，
跟货他等于说是公司花钱人，
那转给我，
在我的名下去买了货，
最后这个货在仓库，
我能卖掉这些货吗？
那我认为有风险，
因为公司转钱给你，
公司是在谁名下的，
公司没有名下，
他的主公司是在他朋友名下，
但是呢，
我们网店呢，
是在我弟和我表弟名下，
公司转。
钱给你的主体是在谁名下的，
A公司转钱给你A公司是在谁名下的，
那你有风险，
你不要再贪图这个过了。
第4，
我做过三年的销售主管以及培训的课程主管，
做过主播，
自己也在做过短视频和拍摄，
我现在存款差不多有150个，
我该怎么样去规划我的职业，
你就踏踏实实做你的电商吧，
因为你自己做电商以前也每天的销售额可以做到几千块钱，
因为你只是卖货吗？
诶你是自己，
你又对，
你又没有员工，
你又没有什么别的成本的话，
做电商带货就挺好啊。
我能不能理解是因为第二年他不是因为他后悔了来找我，
而是因为他看到我赚钱了才来找我的，
一定是这样，
因为一个男的，
他出现在你生命里，
刚开始的那个形象就非常臭不要脸的，
不给你发工资，
给你出去花钱还是你花钱，
他贬低你，
他瞧不起你，
今年我们在做的这个仓库目前来说投了300个，
但是他和正常的电商区别太大了，
我跟他提过很多意见，
我说电商的主体是产品，
不是仓库，
但是呢，
他就硬要把这个仓库打造的非常漂亮，
我到现在都没有想明白他为什么要做电商，
但是把仓库打造的非常漂亮，
让别人看起来这个老板很有实力，
但是这个仓库里放着一堆垃圾货，
当然很难忘，
动不动的来骂我，
是为什么呢？
姑娘真。
搞笑对于一个这么失败的老登，
你问我为什么他要这么干？
因为他蠢，
因为他不懂电商，
他才这么干，
你还问我为什么他要这么干？
他如果但凡聪明，
但凡理解电商，
他就不至于说亏100万，
不至于这么着钱。
他为什么这么干？
因为他蠢啊，
他认职落后啊，
他不懂电商啊，
所以他这么干啊，
所以他亏钱啊，
就这么简简单的逻辑啊，
行，
那我大概了解了，
嗯，
自己名下的钱我可以提现，
然后我自己去，
我做我的电商对吗？
是的，
没错没错，
嗯，
好，
再见啊，
拜拜，
还特瞧不起那种老灯，
那老公看开眼了是吧？
没有点自我修养吗？
年轻的姑娘跟你在一起怎么了？
不图你能挣钱，
还图你帅啊，
真的有男人的魅力啊，
没点自知之明吗？
我以后要是活成一个老公的话，
我非常有自知之明。
图你肚子大图你秃头图你不洗澡图你老人味儿图你啥？
一把年纪了没点自知之明吗？
还觉得自己是情场老手，
想象中自己长得跟马景涛年轻的时候一样子似的，
多有魅力多有竞张力似的。
女孩也是，
就去给人打工，
人家都不给开工资，
出去吃饭还得你花钱，
而她还是你，
这3点还不知道她是个什么人吗？
那么不要脸的一个老登，
还跟她怀孕，
想什么呢？
记得点赞关注哦。